this place
at Sweet something Bakery one of the
mottos is treat yourself and someone did
just that early Friday we were
definitely shocked to see what we found
when owner Emma Irvine arrived to find
her front door shattered she decided to
check her store surveillance video and
discovered a bizarre overnight break-in
now at first it's like oh another
expense another challenge another hurdle
but you know we watched the video and
couldn't help but have a good laugh the
suspect she says hung around outside for
about 15 minutes even knocking on the
door as if he was like coming to pick up
a cake at 3 P.M not 3 A.M eventually he
kicks in the door and walks in the
suspect tours the store before taking a
seat in the back where he rests and
drinks some water then he grabs a mop
and bucket and goes to work on the
broken glass you know mopping a mop
bucket is not always ideal to clean up
glass but he did the best he could the
suspect then care carefully put on his
sunglasses and snapped a few selfies
with the store's phone which captured
the results it's a little present for us
I guess and took a few cupcakes and went
on his way a box of six chocolate
cupcakes with champagne flavored
buttercream sweet something had to
remake the customer's order
somewhat enamored with their cake
burglar but not so much with the broken
door the bakery is now selling chocolate
champagne cupcakes topped with an orange
sunglass sugar cookie to help pay for
new glass it's one of those situations
you turn lemons into lemonade and you
hope for the best Kristen Robinson
Global News